digamos que comprarse una casa
recientemente por 200 mil pesos y la
manera en la que pudiste pagar esos 200
mil pesos es por qué porque pudiste dar
el 25 por ciento como depósito inicial o
como pago inicial el cual fue de 50 mil
pesos entonces 50 mil pesos de pago
inicial y el balance el otro 75% lo
pediste prestado al banco entonces 150
mil fue préstamo del banco y esto lo
pagas con tus ganancias mensuales que
incluyen el pago del préstamo y los
intereses ahora supongamos que algo pasó
en tu vida que perdiste el trabajo
desafortunadamente o tal vez sobre
estimas te tu habilidad para pagar este
préstamo hipotecario así que se te
dificulta realizar los pagos y bueno tal
vez francamente ya no puede seguir
pagando así que en esta situación
extrema tienes varias opciones de hecho
un par de opciones una de ellas es que
puedes vender la casa entonces puedes
vender
y la otra opción es esencialmente
regresar la casa al banco ajá a esto se
le llama juicio hipotecario en otro
vídeo vamos a analizar más qué pasa en
un juicio hipotecario pero esencialmente
el banco var va a querer obtener la casa
venderla y si no puede la venderá
después pero esto no es una buena opción
para ti porque esto aniquila tu crédito
lo cual hará que se te dificulta
bastante obtener un préstamo de
cualquier tipo especialmente un
hipotecario así que no van a querer
prestarte dinero por bastante tiempo tal
vez varios años así que te vas con esta
opción la de vender la de vender la casa
entonces bueno tal vez
desafortunadamente hubo una gran
deflación en el mercado de viviendas así
que cuando hablas con un agente
inmobiliario él te dice bueno ayer
intentaste todo ya intentaste venderla
por un precio mayor a tu préstamo pero
no te ha funcionado así que estás
obviamente obteniendo ofertas más bajas
tal vez como 120.000 ó 130.000 así que
ustedes analizan esto lo que lo que el
mercado pagaría por la casa
cuenta que lo que más vas a obtener
después de pagar comisiones de bienes
raíces y todo eso obtendrás tal vez
120.000 por la casa y digamos que aún
debes algo muy cercano a 150 mil pesos
entonces tal vez después de un año o dos
aún debes pagar como 140 mil cajas
pongamos si solo puedes obtener 120 mil
por la casa entonces solamente puedes
obtener 120 mil por la casa que haces no
quieres llegar a una situación en la que
vendas la casa por 120 mil y aún deba
150 mil del préstamo entonces tendrás
que aún pagar 30 mil pesos por una casa
que ya ni siquiera tienes eso sería
horrible es cierto entonces qué haces
una opción sería bueno que no siempre es
opción una opción es ir al banco y
preguntar si puedes hacer lo que se
llama una venta corta una venta corta es
esencialmente vender la casa por una
cantidad menor a la que debes del
préstamo entonces es vender la casa lo
voy a escribir aquí así que una venta
corta
vender la casa por una cantidad menor
por una cantidad menor a la que debes o
sea del préstamo y el banco no tiene por
qué hacer esto
primero el banco deberá estar de acuerdo
con esta venta corta porque su préstamo
está asegurado por esta propiedad que
estás vendiendo y en la mayoría de los
casos la razón por la que tú quieres
hacer esta venta corta es porque el
banco tal vez tal vez perdone el balance
del préstamo entonces tú intentas
convencer al banco para que perdone el
balance así que vas al banco inglés les
comentas -bueno perdí mi empleo no puedo
realizar los pagos después de intentarlo
solamente puedo obtener 120 mil por la
casa es lo único que me están dando así
que yo sé les debo 150 mil pero quería
saber si me pueden perdonar a los 30 mil
extra que les debo y tal vez accedan
ahora también en esa situación debes
tener cuidado porque porque eso debe ser
negociado con el banco el banco aún
puede reportarse con las agencias
crédito entonces reportar a las agencias
de crédito y tú no quieres eso eso no es
no es mejor que los juicios hipotecarios
entonces en todo este proceso de
negociación el banco no tiene ninguna
obligación de perdonarte el préstamo y
que tú realices esta venta corta pero
además que no te reporten con las
agencias de crédito no no no tiene
ninguna obligación así que tú tú debes
intentar negociar también eso que no te
reporten con las agencias de crédito
otra situación que puede surgir con la
venta corta es que y de hecho es algo
que no mucha gente piensa es que cuando
tú tienes por ejemplo en este caso 30
mil perdonados entonces tienes 30 mil
perdonados el servicio de impuestos
internacional puede considerar esos 30
mil como ingresos tuyos y tal vez tengas
que pagar impuestos sobre eso ahora
siempre se me pregunta bueno espera
porque si alguien me perdona un préstamo
porque esto se considera como ingresos
manera de pensar en ello es que si el
servicio de impuestos internacionales no
lo considera como ingresos habría un
gran hueco ahí cierto entonces bueno
digamos que yo yo quiero prestarle
dinero a alguien esta soy yo y aquí está
la persona que yo le quiero prestar
podría podría yo prestarle digamos cien
mil pesos entonces luego podría yo
perdonarle ese préstamo eso se traduce a
haber dado esos 100 mil es como haber
esencialmente haber hecho un pago a esta
persona o haberle regalado he hecho un
regalo ajá entonces le perdonas el
ingreso en una venta corta no siempre
podrás hacerlo pero si tu casa se está
vendiendo a una menor cantidad que el
valor del préstamo tal vez vas a querer
negociar con el banco para que permita
vender la casa por una cantidad menor
que el préstamo y la otra opción del
banco sería el juicio hipotecario y
adueñarse de la casa pero también esto
resulta bastante costoso para el banco
aunque las claves aquí lo primordial es
que aunque el banco esté de acuerdo con
dejarte real
la venta corta tú debes asegurarte de
que el banco también perdona el balance
así como que no te reporte con las
agencias de crédito